I've talked a little bit about having
body dysmorphia most of my life like
being weirded out by like never being in
shape enough or never having big enough
muscles or whatever the problem is
seeing something in a mirror that other
people don't see and so I know sometimes
when that flares up when I'm exhausted
when I haven't been taking care of
myself I'll put a t-shirt on and it will
won't feel right and I'll look over at
my wife and say is this shirt okay to go
outside and she'll look at me and say
yes and I have outsourced that to her I
trust her implicitly and I begin to feel
what it feels
like because my body's saying it's not
you shouldn't wear this shouldn't wear
this it's too tight it's too small don't
wear this don't wear this and she said
you look great and so I'm going to begin
to practice feeling what it feels like
when it actually looks great and
sometimes occasionally she'll say no not
today and I don't get my feeling certain
I don't get mad I trust her